such an exciting day you clearly got the
orange memo was this a little
Nickelodeon inspired up of course yes I
mean I had to pull it out for the orange
carpet I'm like a peachy moment would be
good so I'm having so much fun
so cool to see you in this season of
life you don't need me to tell you how
excited we are about Little Mermaid we
just got that new trailer and we finally
got to see a look at Ursula and at Eric
so I'm curious for you you're part of
the movie you're there with everybody
making it which transformation which
character surprised you most oh I
definitely would have to say Melissa I
mean people are gonna be so amazed at
her job with Ursula she's just first of
all she's a beautiful human being but so
talented in the way she just consumes
Ursula is so beautiful so I'm just so
proud of her and I can't wait for people
to see it no I have to imagine Melissa
is quite a lovely human being but as we
know Ursula is not very kind to Ariel so
what is it like in those scenes where
you know she's a nice person but she's
giving you the business yeah you know it
was actually good for the film because
she has this very kind of maternal
trickiness to her when it comes to
tricking Ariel in the film so I kind of
got to be consumed and in her world of
and almost teased and falling into her
spell so it wasn't so much like mean
mean it was like me like you know
looking for a maternal figure yeah you
had to describe Ursula in three words
what would it be amazing legendary
iconic
I gotta tell you I was with your sister
earlier this week I'm so blessed to
spend time with the Bailey sisters and
she's about to drop an album and she's
about to go out on tour and she told me
that this album making it felt like a
Pain release and that when you go to her
show it's gonna feel like a therapy
session is this experience emotional for
you getting to see her step into this
light absolutely I'm so so proud of my
sister and I cannot wait for her album
to come out but she deserves this and
she has been working on this for so long
just similar to this movie for me so we
are like in similar paths right now
where we're getting to release something
that we've been working on so hard and
I'm so proud of her I can't wait for
people to see it did you cry when you
listen to the album I did I've cried
when I hear songs I'm so proud of her
and I just I can't wait and what a
beautiful season of Life For You The
Little Mermaid you've got the color
purple you've got the line I'm curious
when does Halle Bailey take a day for
herself do you have time for a personal
life a self-care day yeah yeah we always
find time I mean I bet you can say the
same you're always busy but you have to
find times to just decompress have some
time for yourself get your nails done I
think after this I'm gonna go to the
nail salon and yeah and then go to nails
and then sleep because I'm tired yeah do
you have time for romance yeah yeah yeah
you know we gotta make time for that
thank you
[Music]